closed or this one ready I don't know if
it's because I'm salty as [ __ ] about the
Jets loss last night or what but the
energy that I'm feeling right now is on
a different level I just needed to make
this video and this is for all my homies
that were supposed to for all my homies
that were supposed to become a [ __ ]
NFL star but they tore two ACLs and now
they're 24 and they don't know where
their life's going for all the people
that were supposed to be a big-time
[ __ ] personnel wall shree cuz they
went to [ __ ] pen or Harvard or
whatever the [ __ ] and their parents
didn't or grandparents did it and they
were gonna do it too and be a hedge fund
this [ __ ] house in the Hamptons that
and they [ __ ] hate it
they hate everybody there with they hate
people that love money more than [ __ ]
anything else and they hate it and
they're 26 and they're in the worst
[ __ ] place in their life right in
here even though they got [ __ ] zeroes
in their bank account because they were
supposed to be a [ __ ] hedge fund Wall
Street mogul but that's not their actual
DNA for all my homies that were supposed
to be the next [ __ ] hip-hop superstar
they grew up with all the people they
knew all the producers they were in the
scene and the clubs at 17 co-signed by
everybody but they just didn't have that
single talent or that song never broke
or they got [ __ ] along the way
mentally because they thought they were
gonna win and they didn't put in the
work in the studio or on paper for all
my homies that were supposed to that are
20 to 29 27 32 34 38 supposed to be a
big-time lawyer supposed to marry the
girl or guy of their dreams supposed to
supposed to supposed to can we [ __ ]
for the first time ever have a
conversation of supposed to - who who
anointed this supposed to for all my
homies that we're supposed to you're
still young as [ __ ] flip the script take
control of your [ __ ] life and realize
you have it all in front of you there's
so much to be done with this [ __ ] where
the world we live in
[ __ ] everybody else is supposed to and
start doing every [ __ ] self